Hmm.
I don't think the day is coming.
Soon when we'll look back at that,
people who believe in God,
we're,
you know,
that was a silly age.
Uh,
although some of us look like,
look,
look at it that way now.
But um,
but clearly the numbers are,
you know,
we're not in the majority yet,
but the fastest growing group,
uh,
best growing religious group,
so called is the nuns.
The Ano.
And people check the box for no
religious affiliation.
Now they're not necessarily atheists or
agnostics,
skeptics,
but they are not affiliated with a
religion.
And so on one level,
I don't care what somebody believes as
long as they leave me alone and they
don't interfere with my rights,
they don't try to kill me and bother me.
Um,
I mean,
you know,
the JW is the Jehovah witnesses.
They come to my door once in a while.
The Mormons come to my door once in a
while,
it kind of amusing.
I invite them in and give him a copy of
skeptic magazine and they're like,
oh,
we better call the the head guy.
Come down here.
That's relatively harmless.
But,
but clearly we see with Islam and,
and that problem of Islamic terrorism,
you know,
religion has to be reformed.
It absolutely does.
I don't worry about the Janes or,
or,
or Jews or most Christians,
uh,
causing societal problems anymore
because they've gone through the
reformation.
Enlightenment,
the age of reason,
the scientific revolution that came out
the other side,
mostly nonviolent.
And,
uh,
you know,
Islam hasn't,
uh,
I think it would be a reform Islam and
then start to wean people off belief in
the supernatural altogether.
You can't do it by Fiat,
but we can inculcate into people's
thinking,
critical thinking about everything,
including God,
throw God into the mix.
That's just another supernatural belief.
And that's what those of us who work in
this area are trying to do.
Uh,
you know,
the different strategies,
you can be aggressive about it.
Like Richard Dawkins and hitch,
you know,
they're,
they're pretty anti anti theist that
works in some cases,
but not other cases,
other areas.
People need to be reeled in slowly,
gently,
you know,
and,
uh,
it's,
that's just a sort of a marketing,
sales and marketing problem.
You know how,
how,
how should we sell our product best?
We call it this.
We use the red logo or the blue logo,
that sort of product,
test those things and see what works.
But we all share this overall goal in a
century or two.
I think it's possible.
No one will believe in God anymore,
almost no one.
Uh,
and that will be good for society.